おっ
[音楽]
voodoo
voodoo ん
どうもみなさんはじめまして
いやー私あのたか先程紹介いただきました高取亮と申します
筑波大学の人文学類で勉強しておりました
こう見えてあの立派な日本前のサラリーマンです
そこで笑いが起こるというのはちょっと想定外だったんですがまぁ基本的に私であの
衆院34くらいこの確保しておりまして
で
まぁこんな感じですあの全部
日本人ですよこれ
須永プリンス大手の前で撮ったんですけど
まあ結構いつもこんな感じできてこれは私の二段になっています
この服がですね家の中でこうやって
山積みになっておりましてだいたいそうですね全部で70着ぐらいあります
全部あの中東の各部族とか色んな国のものを全部集めています
この場合はの小学生もぜんぶつけてですねラクダの丸やてぃくせ強いてもので私が苦節
読みたい書かれたんですけど
ちょっとがまあまあわーその新聞社のか器用なんですよね
そういうふうにいっぱい持っている日本人で多分多分マン個人では日本で一番持って
いるという自信があります
で中東で去年こんな感じですみんな同じ方向を向いていますよ
here いろんなそのなんだろ
現地の方で溶け込んで現地の方であっあーっ
デブなことをやっているというのが私の基本的な活動なんですその結果
ありがたいことにその中東で一番有名な日本人という称号をいただいていろいろやらせ
ていただいております
まあそれに合わせてちょっと私のですねあのまあ説明というか
なんでこんな服を着ているのかそしてその服を着て通じて何をもたらすことができたの
かというのをご紹介させていただきたいと思います
その前にまずはう
こんな感じで電気系統のトラブルでございませんちょっとさっきはいろいろあります
けどね
これはわざとですこれなねなぜかと申しますと
今消えた電気の行動を考えてください
我々と日本と中東の関係
中近東の方から来ている石油の約
去年の時点で中近東の原油依存率はだいたい80%くらいです
高いとか90%近くを洗いしてました
これほど我々のこのあなたの携帯電話の充電に使用
電気に西欧ボロボロの生活に関わっているのに対して皆さんが持ってる中東のイメー
ジってどんなものがありますかねそれはちょっと説明できればと思います中東とか
アラブとか
まあいろんなニュースとかあぁここ最近のニュースもすごいいろいろありますけどね
その部分も不可
目でちょっと色んなケースとかイメージとかをちょっとお話しできればと思います
やっぱりこういうイメージですよね
彫ったものがもうねぇ1秒当たり50万円くらいっていうなんか推計も一つの国がある
んですけどそれぐらいの富を生み出す
席様がいるんじゃないかと豪遊してるんじゃないかとはソイ思う方をいるかを知らせ
それからもしくはこれ昔ながらのオアシスがあって米同院の二方々が生活しててね
ラクダは友達みたいなそんな感じ
世界
もしくはこういう危ないメイジェイもちろん皆さん見たことありますしメディアでも
いっぱいいも流れているのでそういうイメージがあるんじゃないかとそういうふうに
思います
残念ながらいまのそういうイメージは結構古いものです
みてくださいこれはですねラクダのヨーグルト
ラクダの魅力のヨーグルトラクダのアイスクリーム
ラクダは楽だじゃないですよラクダのミルクのアイスクリーム出すそういう風に加工さ
れたりとかですねそういうなんかあぁ私いいものを生み出せるという
そういう場でもありますこんな感じのもうブルージュハリファ皆さんご存知かもしれ
ませんがまあ現時点において世界で一番高いタワーがあったりもしくはですねこれ見て
ください皆んだと思います
これ救急車ですよ
どんな救急車だよって思うんですけどねちゃんとアンプランスてこう書いてますねん
これでまあ運ばれるもしくは
こういうブックフェアとかがるフードみたい世界でもう相当大きな展示会みたいなもの
が起こら行われているそういう
ハブとしての機能の国でもあります
もしくは何百年何千年前のものがもう目の前でもしか操作はれるんですよ
もう私もあの結構生物を実はの触ってきたエルサレムに住んでた時に触ったり日タウン
ですがそこら辺にあるものがも何百年とか何千年前のものなんです
そういう古いものとありますし新しいものが混在する
なかなか素敵な空間
だと思いますです
ではそこの部分のそのこういう風ないろんな中東みたいなものがありますがその中東に
ついてもっと
ご紹介させていただければと思います私は筑波大学を卒業した後もただのサラリーマン
が普通のサラリーマンだったんですがそこでですね
その中東の方にちょっと派遣されるプロプロジェクトがありましてそれであのー
今話題のサウジアラビア
方に行っておりましたそれ以降いろんな国々をぐるぐる回ってその中東のことをよく
知るようになりました
そのときに私に大きなインパクトがありましたじゃあ何でしょう
実は私ですねお酒が全然飲めない体質なんですよ
で
まあ皆さんも経験があるかもしれませんし
久保谷とか10日券とかちょっとここではそれからやめよ
そういうところでですねこうなんかこう先輩からこうやったりとかですねもしくは会社
の上司からこうあったりとかいろんなプレッシャーを受けてきて結構苦労はしてたん
ですねもう
中途のほうに行くとをまだ酒が飲めないのか素晴らしいな
お前はそういうふうに作られた素晴らしい男だみたいな形で
逆にほめられたんですよ今まで日本で生活して人生でそんなことって1回もなかったん
ですよ
それはもう私の中の大きな転換でした
でこの中東というその環境みたいなところをご説明しますと
これあの私へ降下さとかさせてるんですけどこの時の気温がですね確か52度くらいで
こっちの方に至っては60を超えてました
軽くなんかもそこら辺で低温火傷ができるようなレベルの
そういうふうな過酷な環境なんですねその環境の中で
やっぱりこういうあの肌を晒さない
を長い裾の長い服を着ることによって6号湿度が低いので直射日光を下げたこういう
民族衣装が凄い好まれています私はこれをですね
完璧に着こなす
ことによって現地の人たちと完全に溶け込んで
作法とか所作もしくはそのそうですねジェスチャーあるしてまさにジェスチャーとか
いろんなものとかを覚えて
溶け込むことをしてきました
そしてこんな感じで巻き方とかいろいろあるんですけど私が白いものをつけたり赤白
だったり
部族のコーディネートとかいろいろ変わるんですね
でまぁあの10社の一つみたいなものなんですけどあの私のやり方としてこういう風な
トラディショナルな現地のものと日本のものを組み合わせて日本人という形も残し
ながら現地のものに合わせるというそういう仕組みをやってましたただ気をつけなけれ
ばいけないポイントで見てください
単に中東の湾岸地域といってもこれだけ違いがあるんですよ
ではこの組み合わせ方によってお前は何なり部族とか何な理系とかそういうのが全部
違うんですね
この違いをですねはっきり分かって着こなしてる人間ってほとんど実はいないと思い
ますあのーここには山折りにしてるんですけどこれサウジだと山折り谷折りだと違う
ところとか色々なあの
を
タイプがあるんですけどまあ中にあの今のシーズン的にあの席イオンコスプレをして
いる方々がいるんですけどまぁあれ私ですねあんなもとんでもないですね
あの
まぁなんと申しますかねあの
うーんあまり良くないとしか言いようがないんですけど着方とかを完璧にマスターして
着こなすことは相手に対するリスペクトにはなるのでそこの部分が私が受け入れられた
掃除だと考えられます
でもう一個のですねポイントもチョコ写真しつこいんですけどあの
ポイントが私実はこんな確保するわりにはアラビア語まだまだダメなんですね
筑波大の話閃光中国とトルコなんですよであの
私がちょっと面白い間違えというか行っちゃった間違いの一つがあって良いですかこの
口ひげの部分のことをアラビアグレー作数買っています
でこういう卵焼きの料理のことを尺数買っています佐藤者の違いですねこれが何が起き
たかというと
私は口ひげを食べたっていうふうにいろんな人に連行して
お前は口ひげを食べたのかうんとても今日朝食べて美味しかったっていう風に言って
お前は口ひげを食べる男かみたいな感じで
いろんな人に突っ込まれて結構恥をかいたことあります
こういう風なですね言語ネタ的なミステークみたいなものは結構いっぱいあります
これはまだ大人しい方ですたまにとんでもない言葉言ったりとかする方法あるんで結構
危ないってのがあるんですよただそういうふうな言語的なミステークもうまく
を拾って面白いこいつは面白い男だなとか
こいつはなんかあのブルー暮らしてるんだなというところを組んでいただいて
まあ何とか皆さんと仲良くなっていったというのがあります
同時に言語もそうですしもちろん
表面的なものそうですけど歴史とか私歴史学専攻なので歴史を勉強することの重みを
すごい感じますこれあの私が個人で作ったものです
王族の系統とか誰がどの市定例どういう部族なのかとかそういうところ本当に細かく
勉強しました
そして話すっていうのは現地の人にからするとびっくりします
なんでかというと例えばですよあの紋付袴の姿の外国人が
脇差させて墓も書いてんですよ上下までつけて
いや俺は
足利将軍だったら足利よ捨てるを評価するとかそんなこと言ったらすげーなーこいつっ
てなるのと同じことなんですよ
私は三代目のファイサル国を好きだよと言ったらすげーなお前みたいなんで話せるわけ
ですね
でこういう要素ももちろん重要です
でそういう風な積み上げとか積み重ねをやることによってその普通のサラリーマンとか
普通の駐在員とかがなかなかできないようなレベルのことまでできるようになりました
例えばこれはですね現地の自動車王といわれる
個人38000億ぐらいの方にご招待いただいてプレゼンをやった時のものとか
あのサウジアラビア国王陛下がいらっしゃった時のあのまあコメンテーターとして呼ば
れたりとか
なかなかの普通の形ではできないような経験をさせて頂く事がありました
その結果今はですねインスタグラムがだいたい7万人くらい
twitter が3万人くらい全部アラブ人から
日本人が数百に入ってるかもしれませんがフォローされています
そうですねまあ今のところその
ソロの数では日本で一番の数で
数になっていますので中東の一番有名な日本人という風な消防いただいております
いいわ私の友達て3位が私のアラビア語の主将です
けっこうこれ貴重な写真なんですけどこれサウジアラビアの写真ですよ
現地の女性たちファンと一緒にパーティへ行っても写ってる様子なんですね
あの弾マアムで行われたイベントでだいたい300人くらい来てくれたのかなああそれ
でなんかあの私の心私の功労をずっとやってくれたりとかしてくれるんですけどにょ
なかなか貴重
オーナーそうですねあの絵だと思います
こういうのをまあやってこれ皆さんちょっとわからないこの赤白のものがでしたよく見
た後手裏剣になってるのわかります
が私がですね実はこういう細かい俺は東京砂漠出身のベルみんな見たそのほど自己紹介
言うんですこの学校でそうすると思うし合おう
東京サーバからよきたなぁとかその話をするんですけどそういうふうな細あの日本の
アピールをしながら駐屯時計 at こういう風なわかりやすさっていうのすごく大事
なんですね
で日本の方も評価が日本のポジションを置きながらも中東の事を好きだよというのを
何かしらの表現で表す
浦和レッズのファンの方がいたらね
ある日あるに買ったよねまぁそれは置いておいて私はサウジアラビアのチーム応援して
日本人の浦和レッズサポーターの方とこれこれもないですねやっぱり中途の方から
すごいやっぱ受け入れられたりとかしました
こういうわかりやすさが結構大事だったと思います
こういうわかりやすさと申しますかこれはあのパレスチナ難民時チェックで型の演武を
させて頂いた私テールがやるのを大変おこがましいのですが
させていただいたときに千輪の小学生中学生の子供たちが見てくれました
こういうふうにあの
まあ日本文化を伝えるで向こうのことも評価するみたいな形でもう分かりやすさをです
ね全面に出してアピールをしたことによって私のその
なんでしょう in スターみたいなものとかあとそういう sns みたいなものが
どんどん拡大していったんだと考えられます
そうですねまあそして次に思うこと
ちょっと写真とだいぶずれてまああの
いつでも来てるんだよというアピールなんですけど
あの次に思うことはですね私がこうやっていろいろな写真を出したことによってあなた
がたが中とのことをよく知っていただいているとただその中東の文化をですね
もうちょっとこう理解して尊重して好きになってもらいたいというもちろんそのために
私は今日ここに立っています
それの中にあるのはやはり日本と柱との関係を良くしたい
いろんななんかステレオタイプとか考え方とかあるかもしれませんがその相互理解の
ための情報量を少しでも多く提供したいとそういう気持ちを純正に守った上でやって
いるところがあります
そうですねそういう新しい世界を知るってことは皆さんやっぱり新しい世界って
どんどん
ワクワクドキドキしません新しい世界です
シンプルに
ワクワクが止まらない
これなんだかっていうと中東のこれボディビル選手権なんですよ
これ私がなぜかですねこの168センチ62キロですね貧弱ボーイはなぜか旬菜ずに
ずっと座ってるんですよ
これを約7時間ぐらい600人か500人くらいかな筋肉をずっと見せ続けられたけど
もうああ
凄かったろうこれなぜ呼ばれたかというと相互理解のその果てで日本人でそういう中東
に興味があるって言う人がいるって事は向こうのそのプロテイン会社の偉い人から入っ
て
でも呼ばれてこの
筋肉の狂乱を見せていただいたというわけです音あんまりバカにしちゃいけませんよ
これも一つの相互理解中東でボディビル選手権が今度大々的にあるって皆さん知ら
なかったですよね
賞金金額優勝初期一銭もんですよ
こ前の大会ではこれ今のとこ世界で一番なんですそれがクウェートであるんですよ
1 protein という会社をやってるんですけどねイメージなかったでしょ
だから少しでもこのネガティブなイメージとかをこういう世界もあるんだ同じ人間なん
だというのをアピールしたいと思います
やっぱりその理解をするにあたってはすごく大変なことが多いです
なんでこの人たちはこういう風に考えるのかとかなんでこんなアクションをするのかと
いうことを知っていくにはやはり情報量の積み重ねが圧倒的必要なわけです
まあその情報を積み重ねるということにあたってはやはり好きというその気持ちの動機
づけが必要だと思います
やっぱりそのスキを好きで終わらせずに
こういうふうにある程度発散するような形ってすごく大事だと思います
それに対して努力をしてますかっていうのはありますもし努力をしているのですから
まあ好きだから努力する当然ですよねそれをもっと表に出しましょう
そういう架け橋になるような存在になりましょうと世界は広いんです
その広さをやっぱりもっと他の人に見せる努力をしてみませんかっていうのが私の提案
なんです
その自分の好きなものというのがやっぱり自分だけが選ぶものなんですよ
その好きなところにやっぱり飛び込んでいるのは自分の好きという意志があってこそ
それを初のする張ってもやっぱ必要なわけですね
私はちょうどですねなぜね私が有名になったかというと sns の勃興期にちょうど
私がこういうアピールをしてたっていうのが全ての始まりなんですだからそのスキを
表現するっていうのはまあ個人レベルで十分できることなんです
それが一介のサラリーマンであった私が10万人もフォロワーを抱えるようになった一
つの原因だと考えられます
その好きなものというのは私はこれ中東の衣装をいつでもいろんなところに来ていると
いう面白さを出してますがその好きなものが機会かもしれないし
もしくは何かしらのアクティビティーかもしれないもしかしたら無機物かもしれない
どう打つかもしれないひとによっては音だかもしれませんそれはもう各人の自由だと
思います
そしてそのスキをですねもっとこう終わらせ
せずに広げてそしてその架け橋になって髪廊してそういうのをやってみたいっていうの
を思います
そうですねいろんなその見たことのない世界を見るっていうのはやっぱりさっきも
シンプルにワクワクが止まらないという世界があると思うのでそこのところに自分自身
はもっとこの学校を渡して東京で東京都内で歩くのって結構恥ずかしかったんですが
最初
でももう慣れました自分がそういうのをやっているということを見てくれる人たちが
たくさんいるからです
そういう仲間を作るってことすごく大事なことでありますし
やっぱり証言しないとそういう仲間の死だして集まってくれないんですよ
だから恥ずかしがらずに自分の
を押すといいますがこれは譲れない
これは3世帯だしたいという気持ちをですね合わせる事って大事だと思います
それを架け橋という言葉じゃなくて私は影の大使と
車道アンバサダーと呼んでいます私もある意味影の大使として中東のいろんな国々を
つなげるように努力しています
最後にあなたがたにその問いかけをしたいと思います
あなたの好きなものはなんでしょうかあなたがぴったりな場所とか
空間とかそれ存在はありますでしょうかもしそういうのがあったらぜひぜひ
どんどんそれを尊敬してウソン努力をして広げていってくださいそしてみんなでそれを
共有したいと思います
その共有に対して一方ぜひ踏み出してほしいと思います
ご静聴ありがとうございます
[拍手]